(upbeat music)
Demi Lovato, the Sorry Not Sorry singer,
clearly making no apologies for who she is
or who she loves.
What is it like for you to sort of open up your world?
Scary?
It's scary for sure.
I talk about a lot of things
that I haven't talked about in interviews.
Tweeting quote,
"If you're that curious about my sexuality,
"watch my documentary."
Her YouTube special, Simply Complicated,
will premier in October.
The topic of her sexual orientation
became a source of speculation last week
when she was photographed holding hands
with DJ Lauren Abedini at Disneyland.
I'm a single 25 year old woman living on her own,
and I really feel like an adult.
♫ Feelin' like a 10
♫ The best I ever been
I feel like I've done a lot of growing
and my album is a result of that.
Making no apologies for what it took
to get to this healthy place of strength and gratitude.
♫ Baby I'm sorry
♫ I'm not sorry
I was exclusively behind the scenes
of Demi's Vevo live performance.
It premiers September 29th,
the same day her new album, Tell Me You Love Me, drops.
There are some interesting song titles,
and of course you released the track listing on Instagram.
♫ You
♫ Don't do it for me anymore
So You Don't Do It For Me Anymore, as a song,
for me it has a double meaning.
I'm breaking up with my old self,
and my addiction, and my alcoholism,
not going back to those old ways
that I always resorted to,
because it doesn't do it for me anymore.
♫ Stop feeling bad for yourself
I used to feel sorry for myself.
Now I have a different perspective on life
where I'm feeling grateful and happy
and I'm just in a totally different place.
(upbeat music)